bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette première édition de l'année à 2014
du journal de la rédaction le 7 8 l'actu
il est bien 18h si vous nous suivez en
direct et je vous souhaite au nom de
toute l'équipe de téléfiles une
excellente année voici à présent les
principaux titres les principaux sujets
de ce 2 janvier la cigogne il est passée
à l'hôpital Mignot au Chesnay un
reportage auprès des premiers heureux
parents de l'année les vacances de Noël
c'est cadeau c'est bon repas et ses
cours de soutien quand les élèves
planchent entre deux réveillons la
direction Voisins-le-Bretonneux pour
suivre les leçons de l'association
Archimède la délégation yvelinoise du
Secours populaire solidaire jusqu'au
dernières heures de l'année avec un
repas qui a été organisé vous l'avez vu
au bateau parisien et puis premier volet
à de la rétrospective de l'année 2013
les moments forts dans le département ce
sera à suivre dans quelques instants
c'est toujours un événement dans une
maternité l'arrivée et du premier bébé
de l'année dans les Yvelines à l'hôpital
Mignot au Chesnay nous sommes allés
rencontrer de repars qui ont vécu un
réveillon un peu agité le reportage de
Yolaine Torres et d'Élodie moine
Luca n'a pas encore de jour mais à
minuit 44 le 1er janvier 2014 le
nouveau-né est toujours mieux dans les
bras de sa maman à l'hôpital du Chesnay
c'est l'un des tous premiers bébés de
l'année
né à 37 semaines et quatre jours Luca
devait normalement arriver le 25 janvier
sa maman a subi une césarienne le soir
du 31 décembre un réveillon plus que
mémorable
la grossesse des péripéties
Luca fait partie des cinq bébés venus au
monde le 1er janvier à l'hôpital du
Chesnay l'année dernière l'établissement
a accueilli 2210 nouveau-nés
et on marche de ses naissances
réjouissant sachez que les sages-femmes
poursuivent leur mouvement de grève tout
en continuant à travailler depuis la
mi-octobre et elle réclame à travers
toute la France un statut médical est
davantage de reconnaissance le dialogue
engagé avec la ministre de la Santé
Marisol Touraine doit aboutir sur des
décisions fermes concrètes en mars
prochain
solidarité 50 seniors yvelinois isolé
ont terminé 2013 en beauté sur la scène
au pied de la Tour Eiffel la Fédération
des Yvelines de Secours Populaire a
organisé en après-midi de détente avec
des repas à bord des bateaux parisiens
le président national de l'Association
Julien Leprêtre était également présent
Olivier Maniscalco et l'audimoine
une croisière sur la scène pour voguer
hors du quotidien le 31 décembre une
cinquantaine de personnes âgées isolées
étaient invités par le Secours populaire
des Yvelines pour un déjeuner convivial
en bateau-mouche un bon repas une
chanteuse de cabaret qui reprend les
grands airs français le tout entouré des
plus beaux monuments parisiens tout
était réuni pour sortir ses seniors d'un
quotidien morose parfois ampli de
solitude
un rêve depuis X années j'ai pas pris de
temps comme ça de faire mon mari il y a
pas longtemps donc passons et vraiment
une journée une journée inoubliable un
repas on ne peut rien dire c'est super
génial une ambiance des amis des voisins
rien à dire trop belle journée a
vraiment à garder en rêve et en au fond
de la tête
on a aussi une pensée pour les personnes
âgées qui ont des conditions de vie
difficiles mais en plus qui souffre
beaucoup de l'isolement et de leur
offrir une croisière de riche pour les
pauvres pour nous c'est vraiment un et
il faut remercier les amis des Yvelines
c'est une très très bonne initiative
nous avons beaucoup de personnes seules
et
le problème c'est qu'elle n'ose pas le
dire donc elles ont un peu honte de leur
situation et on n'arrive pas à les à les
regrouper tous pour pouvoir
qui profite d'une journée telle que tel
que celle-ci pour avoir à Élancourt nous
avons un plus de 200 familles dans le
besoin et nous n'avons pu avoir que
cette personne qui ont voulu venir
le repas soutenait cette fois le midi
mais à l'avenir le Secours populaire
souhaiterait accompagner ces personnes
isolées lors du réveillon de la nouvelle
année en France près de 5 millions de
personnes sont aujourd'hui seul soit 11%
de la population parmi les seniors le
chiffre est plus alarmant encore avec
une personne isolée sur cinq chez les
plus de 75 ans
toujours à propos du Secours populaire
des Yvelines soirée est organisée
prochainement afin de récolter des fonds
une soirée jazz avec repas et tombola
attrap avec un droit d'entrée à 15 euros
réservation par téléphone ou par mail
avant le 17 janvier une opération qui
permet de financer les diverses
activités du Secours populaire les
chiffres du chômage dans les Yvelines
ils le sont pas bons fin novembre 80 500
personnes étaient inscrites à Pôle
emploi dans le département c'est 0,3% de
plus qu'en octobre et surtout cela porte
là où Samuel à 7,5% principal victimes
de ces mauvais chiffres les seniors et
les moins de 25 ans pour évoquer les
perspectives de reprise de l'emploi dans
le département la santé des entreprises
également rendez-vous ce jeudi soir dès
18h30 pour fileco éclaire Cambier reçoit
le président du Medef départemental
émission également en replay sur notre
site internet dans la soirée
toujours en proie des difficultés
économiques le centre de loisirs en
inclusion collective Guyancourtois du
fun pour tous c'est son nom continue
d'accueillir des enfants souffrant de
déficience mentales pendant cette
seconde semaine des vacances scolaires
les jeunes ont découvert cette fois-ci
la cuisine avec le grand chef Canoa
Arnaud tabarrec Le Parrain également de
cette association
en fonction de son handicap chaque
enfant est plus je découpe les fruits ou
presque les oranges au menu ce midi une
raclette et une salade de fruits pour le
moins exotique en dessert confectionné
aux côtés d'un grand chef on a fait
plein de flux différents alors il y
avait des mangues il y avait des fruits
du Dragon il y avait aussi des pommes
des bananes quelque chose qui leur parle
et puis à côté de ça on leur fait
découvrir des nouvelles saveurs des
nouvelles textures des nouveaux goûts
des nouvelles odeurs et on sent qu'ils
sont super réceptifs quoi ils sont ils
sont très curieux en fait lors de notre
première venue il y a un mois du fun
pour tous devaient faire face à un
manque de 50 000 euros réduction des
effectifs et du temps de travail oblige
les employés sont toujours au chômage
partiel mais l'accueil des enfants ne
s'arrête pas pour autant un dossier a
été donc déposé à l'agence régionale de
santé une rencontre est prévue avec le
Conseil Général et le préfet a été saisi
du dossier de quoi être optimiste pour
la nouvelle année mais ce centre de
loisirs en inclusion collective n'est
pas encore sauvé avec la direction
départementale du travail on a
on a arrêté une date donc à fin février
pour le chômage partiel donc on devrait
reprendre une activité normale début
mars après je peux pas vous dire ça va
dépendre de la situation financière si
la situation financière reste comme elle
est on redemandra une autre période de
chômage partiel si ça s'améliore et ben
je pense qu'on pourra reprendre une
activité normale en 2012 du fun pour
tous a accueilli 84 enfants souffrant de
déficience mentales
issus de 25 communes des Yvelines
la culture une galerie de photos
virtuelles c'est ce que propose deux
jeunes entrepreneurs les internautes
peuvent y acheter leur photographie
d'art à Vélizy 2 c'est le lieu où cela
se déroule les fondateurs de Pixo polyta
n'exposent quelques-unes de leurs œuvres
et qui sont proposées ils expliquent
aussi leur concept store et clairs
Cambier et Elodie moine les ont
rencontrés
dans la galerie marchande de Vélizy 2 ce
magasin éphémère propose des
photographies d'art un espace assez
réduit mais l'ensemble de la collection
est visible via ses tablettes un nouveau
concept de vente de Point Zéro vous avez
accès en fait à une visualisation de
chacun des formats et de chacune des
finitions grâce à l'application par
exemple si vous souhaitez un petit
format classique Miss oumary Louise et
cadre vous pouvez le voir ici et bien
sûr voir le rendu que cela donnera chez
vous la galerie virtuelle propose 10 000
photographies du monde entier un jury
d'experts les sélectionne avec les deux
fondateurs Paul-Henry et Romain leur
édition est limitée de 50 à 500
exemplaires pour des prix aussi entre 29
et 450 euros la société a été lancée en
octobre 2012 alors que ces jeunes
entrepreneurs étaient encore étudiants
d'échanges à l'étranger on était
étudiants moi j'avais passé beaucoup de
temps à Shanghai et en arrivant à Reims
la ville dans laquelle on étudie je
souhaitais découvrir mon appartement
d'une d'une photo une belle photo de la
skyline Shanghai et j'ai rien trouvé sur
internet ni dans les magasins de déco et
je me suis rendu compte de deux choses
que j'étais loin d'être le seul à
chercher des photographies de lieu
particulier qui avait du sens pour moi
photos d'art pour découvrir l'intérieur
et l'autre chose c'est qu'il y avait
énormément de photographes de talent
près à exposer et à vendre des
photographies de grande qualité de
toutes ces grandes villes sans
expérience professionnelle romain et
Paul-Henri se sont fait hypolis par des
accélérateurs d'entreprises leur coach
les ont aidés à lever 230 000 euros de
fonds le mois dernier prochaine étape
être présent physiquement dans les
grandes villes de France il reste d'ici
là accessible en ligne et jusque fin ni
à Vélizy
les vacances ne sont pas tout à fait
terminées pour les scolaires et pourtant
certains profitent encore de cette
période pour réviser reportage de
Catherine zulato Anthony rescier
Jonathan Wilman auprès de l'association
Archimède
il profite de leurs congés pour réviser
comme à chaque vacance scolaire
l'association Archimède propose des
cours de soutien cela se passe à Voisins
le bretonneux ce jeudi matin le son de
mathématiques en petits groupes Antoine
lycéen est assidu à ses cours depuis
deux ans au début c'était mes parents la
première fois il y a 2 ans et puis du
coup c'est moi qui est un peu sollicite
un peu mes parents quand je me sens pas
en difficulté on est moins nombreux il y
a un prof un prof pour 6 élèves donc
c'est beaucoup plus facile ils sont
forcément plus attentifs et puis d'une
part parce qu'ils sont moins nombreux et
surtout parce que là ils sont plus
demandeurs demandeurs pour recommencer
les exercices du premier trimestre mais
également revoir les bases
d'apprentissage et les méthodes de
travail ce qui manque souvent le plus
pour acquérir une bonne autonomie cette
situation tout petit groupe ça permet à
l'enseignant de travailler vraiment
individuellement avec chacun et une fois
qu'on a expliqué qu'on a donné bien sûr
quelque chose à faire parce que ça passe
beaucoup par l'application des méthodes
et applications tout de suite sur des
sujets et des exercices et bien ça
permet après l'élève il est tout seul
avec son problème et c'est très
bénéfique bien que ça puisse un peu les
stresser ils sont dans une situation ils
sont pas notés donc là c'est acquérir
aussi de l'autonomie à l'issue de ce
stage un bilan sera donné aux familles
dans la moitié des cas les professeurs
d'Archimède conseillent de poursuivre
ses cours de soutien cours qui sont
aussi organisés de façon hebdomadaire
pendant toute l'année il faut compter 16
euros pour une heure de soutien pour un
collégien et jusqu'à 18 euros de l'heure
pour un lycéen
et durant les prochains jours nous
reviendrons sur les événements qui ont
fait 2013 dans les Yvelines le premier
volet de notre rétrospective nous nous
attardons au premier trimestre de
janvier et donc à mars
2013 la crise économique est toujours
présente elle frappe même de plein fouet
les 1000 salariés du Virgin Megastore
l'enseigne de produits culturels déjà
mis à mal depuis plusieurs années par la
concurrence d'Internet et ce virage de
la vente en ligne mal négociée confirme
la cessation de paiement dès le 9
janvier 26 magasins dont celui de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux fermeront 6 mois
plus tard après des scènes d'émeutes
lors d'une ultime série de soldes
demain vous verrez on est on est capable
on est déterminé on est capable de se
battre comme des lions pour empêcher le
chômage de ravager la vie de millions de
gens pendant que les autres s'en mettent
plein les poches j'ai le dessert baisse
des effectifs mais maintient des usines
françaises jusqu'en 2016 l'accord de
compétitivité de Renault et signé le 13
mars entre la direction et les trois
principaux syndicats une signature après
de longues semaines de contestation
comme ici dans les Yvelines à Flins au
cœur de l'hiver le mariage pour tous des
chaînes les passions alors qu'ils
discutaient le projet de loi à
l'Assemblée les opposants à l'ouverture
du mariage au couple de même sexe
multiplient les actions de nombreuses
manifestations sont organisées notamment
à Versailles une pétition est aussi
relayée à travers la France au départ du
Chesnay elle obtient plus de 500 000
signatures c'est la révolte citoyenne
c'est aujourd'hui le pouvoir va passer
dans la rue et la contestation se
poursuit jusque dans les amphithéâtres
de l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin invité à débattre le
rapporteur de la loi Erwan Binet et pris
à partie par des manifestants et doit
être évacué par la police pendant que
cette scène fait le tour des médias
nationaux les étudiants décompresse loin
d'imaginer l'annonce qui sera faite en
décembre d'une possible fermeture de
leur université en faillite il danse la
folie du Harlem shake vit ses derniers
instants
un autre dossier qui préoccupe le
gouvernement ce début d'année 2013 la
mise en place des nouveaux rythmes
scolaires la réforme doit débuter dès
septembre sur la base du volontariat des
communes et elles sont peu nombreuses à
vouloir se lancer une dizaine dans le
département parmi lesquels Poissy outrap
pour la majorité des villes il faudra
donc attendre un an supplémentaire et le
risque de voir ce sujet déjà peu
populaire devenir un enjeu de la
campagne des municipales les municipales
à un nom du premier tour l'ancienne
ministre Chantal Jouanno se rend à
Magny-les-Hameaux pour soutenir la
candidature d'Aurore berger elle se
présente face au maire sortant
socialiste et veut marquer les esprits
Gérard Larcher Benoît paru feront par la
suite le déplacement pour l'épauler
manier une commune aux rêves de
l'emporter la présidente de l'UMP dans
les Yvelines Valérie Pécresse afin de
peser un peu plus sur l'agglomération de
50 ans en Yvelines bastion socialiste
dans un département très à droite
il cuisine depuis l'âge de 11 ans on
travaille pour la société le nôtre à
plaisir et tout lui sourit Thibault
Ruggeri décroche le Bocuse d'Or grand
prix international de cuisine les
épreuves se déroulaient à Lyon c'est son
turbo aux perles d'infusion aux herbes
qui aura fait la différence
une fierté sachant qu'il y avait une
grosse responsabilité de représenter la
France donc vraiment extrêmement content
et énormément d'émotions enfin le début
de l'année 2013 est aussi l'occasion de
célébrer et quelques anniversaires
symboliques le Centre Aquatique du Lac à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et l'estaminet
lieu dédié à la culture à
Magny-les-Hameaux fête leurs 10 ans et à
Versailles la cité royale célèbre dans
le même temps les 400 ans de son célèbre
jardinier André Le Nôtre une année
complète de festivités débute le 12 mars
la suite de cette rétrospective jusqu'à
la fin de l'année 2013 ce sera à suivre
à partir de demain vendredi dans Le
Journal de la rédaction l'actualité en
2013 a également été marqué à
l'international par le passage du
cyclone ayan aux Philippines des pointes
devant à plus de 350 km/h enregistrés
300000 habitations détruites ainsi que
des milliers de morts le 17 novembre 63
pompiers français étaient envoyés sur
place afin de venir en aide aux
populations parmi eux cinq yvelinois
sous l'autorité du capitaine cédric
dufeuil est en ligne avec nous bonsoir
capitaine du feu bonsoir quelles ont été
vos missions sur place et combien de
temps a duré votre intervention
alors la durée de
la
de l'opération a consisté dans un
premier temps à faire des
reconnaissances donc par hélicoptère et
par voie terrestre nous avons été
projetés donc l'affection Île-de-France
au nord de l'île de Sebu et j'ai pu
constater la base les dégâts
particulièrement importants puisqu'on
était en plein dans la trajectoire du
cyclone beaucoup d'habitations détruites
alors ce sont des habitations qui sont
faites avec quelques poteaux en bambou
et deux trois plaques de tôle pour faire
la toiture plus d'électricité
les besoins concernés plutôt de l'aide
aux sans-abri plutôt que de l'aide
alimentaire qui fait déjà à peu près
bien organisé sur place et ce que j'ai
vu aussi rapidement c'est que les
enfants quand ils continuent d'être
accueillis dans les écoles
participer au déplaît malgré les risques
de chute les risques de blessure des
choses
comme ensuite passé cette mission de
reconnaissance vous êtes intervenu aussi
pour aider à reconstruire par exemple
remettre en état certaines maisons
certains sites médicaux absolument donc
toujours en course à patient avec les
élus locaux j'ai fait le choix et je
l'ai proposé au chef de détachement
français de ne pas intervenir sur les
bâtiments d'habitation individuelle
puisque j'avais pas les moyens de
traiter toutes les habitations donc on a
plutôt ciblé des bâtiments public
nous avons également réactivité
plusieurs salles de classe et des locaux
administratifs et techniques donc là ça
consistait à de la réflexion de
charpente de toiture de bachage on a
traité plus de 1000 mètres carrés de
toiture dans ces deux semaines là
nous avons aussi remis en état une
maison des naissances qui a permis qui
permet maintenant aux femmes portables
d'accoucher dans des conditions
d'hygiène on va dire plus favorables on
voit justement quelques-unes des photos
que vous avez réalisées lors de
l'intervention sur place photo réalisée
par les services des pompiers des
Yvelines quel a été l'accueil de la
population pendant ces deux semaines
alors l'accueil il a été vraiment très
très surprenant
enfin le comportement de la population
moi m'a beaucoup étonné au départ
puisque malgré les circonstances
dramatiques et notre incapacité
du moins à traiter toutes les demandes
individuelles les Philippins nous ont
accueillis avec le sourire tout le temps
ils n'ont de cesse de nos grands
remercier
beaucoup d'entre eux d'ailleurs sur son
portés volontaire pour nous aider sur
les chantiers ils nous ont même
accueilli pour passagers
pas grand chose enfin ils ont
certainement faire plus que que
ça c'était vraiment très surprenant et
très très agréable c'est ce qui vous a
marqué véritablement une fois intervenu
sur place donc je rappelle que vous
étiez aux Philippines avec cette
délégation de deux pompiers 63 en tout
pompiers français qui ont fait le
déplacement donc au mois de novembre
dernier depuis votre retour vous prenez
des nouvelles de des populations sur
place est-ce que d'autres interventions
ont été programmées aussi
alors nous avons des nouvelles via le
chef de détachement français en fait qui
est en contact constant avec l'ambassade
je sais que les efforts continuent sur
place
à ma connaissance par contre il y a pas
eu d'autres entités françaises
gouvernementales en tout cas qui ont été
envoyés vous êtes habitués intervenir
sur ce genre de mission là c'était une
première pour cette délégation notamment
yvelinoise 5 pompiers et Vinois
mobilisés alors c'est pas une première
je pense notamment à Haïti
on vient ces dernières manches c'est
vrai que sapeurs-pompiers
à l'étranger on intervient assez assez
rarement on ne t'avait un plus
volontiers plus facilement en métropole
suite à des tempêtes notamment ou en
termes de formation notamment sauvetage
des blements et la spécialité qui permet
de rechercher des victimes et de faire
des sauvetages suite à des séismes là on
fait des formations à l'étranger assez
régulièrement ça veut dire que vous êtes
formés pour ce type d'intervention oui
pas
donc est-ce que d'autres interventions
prochainement seront prévues ne
serait-ce qu'à la Réunion par exemple
pour l'instant et pour moi un peu trop
tôt de vous répondre à cette question je
sais que c'est un sujet d'actualité au
niveau de du ministère là donc
éventuellement une délégation ce sera ce
sera sur en tout cas merci d'avoir été
en ligne avec nous capitaine du feu vous
dirigez donc les opérations pour la
délégation locale aux Philippines en
novembre dernier après le passage de ce
cyclone à Yann voilà nous refaire mon
cette rétrospective de l'année 2013 pour
ce soir en tout cas le journal revient
vendredi elle nous parlerons notamment
de l'ouverture de cours de longue des
signes à Elancourt on se quitte avec vos
résolutions pour 2014 excellente soirée
sur notre antenne
la santé évoluer dans mon travail ça
j'en cours bien m'entraîner et puis
et puis rentrer dans l'école que je
souhaite après le bac
de se faire un peu plus de sport une
bonne santé
et puis
et puis que les enfants
travaillent bien à l'école arrêtez de
fumer absolument
ça ce sera un premier motif arrêtez de
fumer aussi